[Applaudissements]
de notre chaîne qui savent pas qu'ils
sont les animals mais je chaîne je le
sais ça c'est pour ça que je vole des 60
millions $ 11 10 voilà on dépend du
désir si tout d'un coup moi j'ai une
idée en or et que je vais toujours
proposé qu'une fois tous les ans je vais
proposer deux trois idées d'émissions
donc l'anecdote c'est quelqu'un qui sait
même pas pesé sur la charia jusqu'à 1000
fois que des véhicules à bas coût qui
dit la gare et du film black et le
patron de consternants bien mais c'est
vrai un jour de se la raconter nouveau
avec une avec mais c'est hallucinant je
me retrouve avec une drh
oui directrice qui est qui et sur france
2 elle me dit mais vous faites quoi je
juge boulanger à nemours
non elle dira ça marche bien elle
sentait qu'il se passait quelque chose
je sais pas clair et aussi demandé à des
animateurs sur notre chaîne non ça
faisait 15 ans que je faisais sur la
liberté c'est pour ça que moi c'est
d'éviter pendant que fut le seul
animateur que le pathfinder facteurs le
long de ma fille tranquille va peut-être
des gens sur des huit qui te connaissent
pas malgré tout est ce qu'il ya des
business différents c'est vrai c'est une
immense chaîne france télévisions c'est
combien de gens travaillent à france
télévisions on attendait iront la moitié
[Rires]
à l'est d'aix on va se faire un quiz
texte ou thierry mots je vous propose
des blagues autour de la table maudite
si ces textes qui les a sortis au
thierry moreau bien sûr tirer moreau ne
joue pas ça c'est notre scénario
alors si j'envoie un soufflé ou quoi que
ce soit à la mène là bas il a souffert
le monde ça les gars de chez monsieur et
vous préparez vous alors je suis quoi je
suis coffreur dans le bâtiment à vous
êtes gendarmes
c'est les gendarmes qui coffre
d'habitude ex ex à ces textes qui
faisait 15 ans
bon vous êtes frédéric frédéric donc je
suis brest et je suis coffreur donc dans
le bas de gendarmes
chico frères coffreur bancheur donc sur
ses légendes
un tout petit truc
normalement un jean-luc quand tu fais
cette vanne tu n'expliques pas derrière
mais comme on est c'est la deuxième
couche h et obligé elle savait rigoler
avant déjà sur la verrerie goléo savait
rigoler gueule de cuxa fait de rigolade
de couches c'était du crabe et audry de
thierry thierry beccaro et sur le
plateau il faut qu'ils se tiennent à
carreau
c'est le moment ou jamais de faire votre
valérie et thierry se tiennent à carreau
[Musique]
alors quand les enfants sont malades
les gospels on tient bon désolé je veux
pas dire mais il ya plus un style chez
tex permis on dévale ringarde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'étais pour ma taille femme c'est pour
ça parce que j'appellerais tout à fait
possible